so when when sean invited me today i did
think about a few different topics that
i could come and present um and i could
have presented also on readability which
is a recent focus of mine um and i will
mention it at the end of the
presentation because it's a topic in
which i'm actively recruiting uh
collaborators and interns for but i
decided to take the opportunity since
this is a class to give a kind of
summary of the body of work focused
around attention um or another way to
put this is that i'm going to focus on
how human perception can be leveraged
for computational applications um and
i'll show you how that applies to image
processing graphic design processing
and some visualization work as well and
um just as manish said i'm excited about
it particularly because it's a very
interdisciplinary research area and i
think that there's a lot of exciting
prospects and a lot of unanswered
questions and a lot of possibility to
jump in and do cool stuff in this space
and and so i hope that's going to be my
call to action from this talk and um
students i'll get students riled up to
work in this space
um all right so why why is this so
exciting uh well
if you know where people look you have
these enticing sci-fi like applications
um you might be able to take guesses
about what they're thinking or whether
they're struggling or what they're going
to do next and of course
marketers and commercial agencies are
all about that they want to understand
um where someone looks so that they
might predict what that person might be
interested in um so this is an example i
pulled from an
paper from 2018
um that's claimed that claims to predict
um whether viewers are
looking for information or shopping
around so in this case with this eye
movement trajectory
the model would predict that they're
just browsing for information but this
time movement trajectory would be more
indicative of someone who's trying to
shop around on the website and the
examples are my own but um the flavor is
is from that paper
and another example is that um this this
extends not just to the screen
environment but to the physical and
virtual
store environments where saliency is
actually used to figure out how to
arrange products to make them more
attention capturing on shelves
and another customer of this kind of
technology are vr ar and gaming
companies who want to prioritize um
which pixels they render on the screen
at a time this is from my colleague
chief thumb
and the idea is that you don't want to
render all of the pixels in real time
for every frame that would be
computationally uh
too difficult but if you know where
someone's looking or whether it's gonna
where they're gonna look next you can
prioritize that content and the notion
of prioritization using visual attention
is a theme you'll see again and again
throughout this talk
and if we venture further into mind
reading
there's a whole line of work that looks
at the relationship between eye
movements and memory and one of my
earlier papers from my phd
looked at
using the trajectory of eye movements on
an image to predict whether someone
would remember an image at a later point
in time so here's an eye movement
trajectory of someone who remembered
this image
uh later on and here's an eye movement
trajectory of someone who forgot this
image um
even after looking at it for a few
seconds and just as an aside the key
difference between these two
trajectories is that in the first case
um the participant paid attention to the
road signs which is the distinguishing
characteristic making this image
different from other road images whereas
if you just looked at the cars in the
road it would mesh in your brain with
all the other road images you've seen um
but with enough data a machine learning
model could learn some of these
relationships and in a more applied
domain uh eye movements can also be
related to how people explore and
understand information visualizations
and what they recall from them uh at a
later point in time so there's also a
body of work um
in the visualization community that's
very interested in looking at eye
movements and how people explore uh
visual data
but all of these applications that i've
mentioned despite being quite different
they have this uh one important thing in
common which is that their focus on the
individual observer and what they're
thinking or doing and these applications
are exciting because they give us the
possibility to customize to the
individual of observer
and to understand their theory of mind
but there's another set of application
that becomes possible when we aggregate
the attention patterns of many observers
and in this case if we consider the
population perspective
then we can infer general attention
trends and use them to differentiate say
effective from ineffective designs or to
suggest design guidelines or to help
prioritize visual content because where
a population of participants looks tells
us something about what's most
interesting or relevant in that image or
visual
and the rest of my talk will be more
focused on this population perspective
though we're going to come back to the
individual um in the very last few
slides on uh readability
first i do want to give you just a
little bit of background and terminology
so we're on the same page the
traditional way that
attention is usually collected is using
dedicated hardware in this case i'm
showing you
someone in front of an infrared eye
tracker which captures reflections from
the eyeballs and interprets them as
coordinates on the screen for where
someone is looking
and the software that often accompanies
the eye tracking hardware uh parses that
those continuous eye movements into
discrete fixation points using a set of
preset thresholds and that's preset in
the software and that's
sometimes that's proprietary
the scientist
has the fixation points in their hand
and what they can do with them is
frequently they post process them into
fixation maps they can analyze the
fixation points on their own but it's
often helpful to parse them into
these fixation maps you can aggregate
the fixation points of many observers in
order to do that one way you can do that
is just gaussian blurring them and that
way you're representing them as a
distribution that you can either sample
from or interpret as the high density
regions being the ones that
most observers look at or look at for
the longest periods of time so those are
the regions that are most interesting
and um just a disclaimer throughout the
rest of my presentation you're gonna see
heat maps rendered in
every possible way i think i've probably
tried every possible color map and and
that's just by nature of different uh
trying out different visualization
schemes for different publications but
the key
idea is that anytime you see a heat map
it's really representing the same thing
and the way to think about it is the
high density regions are parts of the
visual world that we're trying to
prioritize and that they're intended to
be a proxy of what people would find
most attention capturing uh or
interesting
all right so um saliency models are
computational models that aim to predict
where people look and so what you can
see here is just a few images from a
saliency benchmark that i used to run uh
back at mit and the ground smooth
fixation or you can call them the ground
truth saliency maps of human observers
collected with an eye tracker and then
what you see along the other columns are
different computational models over time
and the way to read this is actually
from right to left because the earlier
models are on the right side of the
screen
uh and i'm just showing you like a small
slither of the models available because
today there must be a couple hundred or
even a few more hundred models saliency
models out there um
either for the same task although some
are specialized for different types of
images and one thing to observe is that
over time they've converged more and
more to look like human brown troops so
today we have really good models to
predict where people look in natural
images and that's why we're seeing more
and more the use of saliency models in
in the industry and i'll show you some
of those applications as well the
earlier models were tended to be more
handcrafted features that would be
combined together
and then the later models as you might
or uh might expect already their neural
network models um
of of human intention and the way these
models are trained is uh by having
paired images most frequently um where
you have an image and then a fixation
map that corresponds to it either
collected using eye tracking or other
methods as you will see soon um and then
a network is then trained on on those
sets of images to learn the correlations
between visual features and what's
interesting in an image or not and then
given an image of test time
these models can run in near real time
and output saliency maps that can be
used for
downstream image processing tasks
so because these neural network models
are really data hungry um starting using
the traditional hardware based eye
tracking methods is infeasible at that
scale and so this has led to
proliferation of methods to crowdsource
visual attention remotely um without an
eye tracker and i like to um put them
into the two categories webcam webcam
based methods um which are based uh on
the premise of capturing the face
detecting it um finding the eyes and
then mapping um the eyes to coordinates
on the screen and the earlier methods
such as the ones on the screen tended to
be pretty coarse in their predictions
but as data sets have increased and as
neural network models have improved
these have also improved and are are
used more and more today uh and this
could use a webcam but it can also use a
cell phone camera and today's cameras
that have depth sensors are doing a much
better job of this so they have more
information um and then the other
category of methods are the ones that
i'm going to focus the rest of my talk
on today because that's my area of
expertise which are i call them to your
clickbase methods but maybe the right
name is more interaction based methods
because it's not just clicks it's
various interactions that you might have
with your mouse cursor keyboard or or
even with your hands as you'll see um
and the difference of these methods from
the webcam-based ones is that they don't
capture the eyes at all instead they are
proxies of what someone might look at or
choose to attend to or find interesting
without capturing uh the eyes and all
these methods what they have in common
is that they are cheap and easy to
collect at scale and this has led to the
development of a toolbox of related
interfaces um for crowdsourcing
attention that i worked on together with
a great group of mit students um the
lead on this project was annelise newman
who is now a stanford phd
and our goal was to bring together the
different methodologies that could be
used
to crowdsource attention uh without
crowdsourcing uh eye movements uh
directly and uh i will go through these
different methodologies and and what
they uh allow us to do um but the code
for all of them the demos we um we make
available to the research community for
further development so feel free to use
it we'll be happy if you find new use
cases for them uh in a kai 2020 paper we
showed that at a course level all these
methodologies uh capture similar
patterns as eye movements which was
really exciting to find and this happens
when you average
again when you take the population
perspective and when you average the
attention pattern over a population of
participants
there are subtle differences between
them um as as you'll see and those are
interesting as well because those point
to unique use cases or applications or
image types for which some interfaces
might be preferable over others
and we'll see that um in the next few
slides as well so one of the first
interfaces that we use at scale to
collect data is bubble view and that's
based on an earlier idea on using the
restricted focus viewer that's um an
older idea that already was intended to
mimic eye movement patterns but this was
really the first time where we
systematically tested it against eye
tracking and looked at um which which
parameters best model uh eye movements
and then use that to collect a
large data set that we could train a
model on so here as you can see
mouse moves around
as someone explores an image and the
blurriness is intended to model this
kind of peripheral viewing
very coarsely and we give them a task in
this case they're viewing the
visualization we give them the task to
describe the visualization to keep them
both to keep them on task but to add
interesting data that we can then link
back to um the their patterns of
attention where did they look and what
they described
um nicely you average the these click
patterns over a population of
participants 20 or 30 um you start to
converge on fixation maps so the the
patterns that we purchased here very
similar to
eye movements that we would have
collected in the lab using an eye
tracker in fact we can account for um
around 90 of eye fixations using these
click maps and that's a good enough
amount for a lot of the uh applications
that we might have in mind
so
this amount of data allows us of course
to train these
data hungry neural network models
of saliency that take as input in this
case they were trained on visualizations
and graphic designs so they can take his
input visualizations and graphic designs
and output heat maps of attention on
them
uh and uh in our west 2017 paper we just
gave some demo applications some toy
applications where you could use these
maps out of the box to already show some
interesting um
thumbnailing or summarization uh results
so here we're just using the predicted
attention map and then we're taking all
the most important
content the most predicted important
content seam carving around it to create
a thumbnail and you can see some of
those other examples at the bottom here
but one thing that stood out for us as
we played with this application is it
was really hard to capture full design
elements you see that some of the text
is getting cut off or some of the design
elements because the data capture
methodology was not uh built to
keep
these design elements intact and
together that's a segmentation problem
and that actually uh moved us to
considering a different
user
interface that would collect a proxy of
attention together with segmentation
all-in-one so let me show you what that
one looks like
uh this is the important ops tool and
this is based on earlier work by peter
o'donovan i believe from 2015 uh and as
you'll see here um the task to
participants um to crowd workers is to
annotate the most important regions on
these graphic designs and this seems
like an instruction that's quite far
from where people are looking and
might appear to be subjective
but what's exciting about it is that if
you average these
individual um important
importance maps or
30 to 40 participants you again start to
converge on something that looks like an
attention heat map and it has this nice
added benefit of having the uh design
elements segmented because that's that
was the annotation test and so they they
come together and so if you want to use
this uh importance heat map to parse the
graphic design you can use these
annotations out of the box
we use this tool for a later paper uh at
west 2020
to collect the importance uh heat maps
for a thousand different designs so you
can see some of the design examples on
the left and the collected heat maps on
the right um and we did this for ads
infographics mobile uis movie posters
and web pages and that data set is also
available
online
and we use this to train a model that
would predict saliency and importance
you could call it either silence your
importance uh for
not just graphic designs but also
natural images so we train this model on
natural images as well um so that there
would be a single one-stop model that
would uh be able to perform this task on
all these different image types and the
idea is that this kind of model that can
transition seamlessly from predicting
saliency on natural images to predicting
importance on graphic designs is better
suited um to be used within real graphic
design
applications in the loop with whatever
the user is doing because a lot of um
posters or advertisements evolve out of
natural images and other components that
get brought together and so having a
model that can understand the natural
image but also the final design is
important
and i'm gonna just show you very briefly
two prototype applications that we built
on on top of this to showcase the real
time capabilities of this model
um and what you're going to see is that
this is a design canvas and and elements
can be dragged and manipulated on this
canvas but in the right hand panel what
you should see is a real-time updated
prediction of what's the most salient
element what are the most salient
elements so you see our
salience heat map
projected there as well and what you see
at the bottom is a set of bar graphs
that correspond to all the design
elements currently on the canvas and the
user can interact with the importance
values of each of those design elements
and ask the an optimization procedure
behind the scenes to change the
placement the sizes and other values of
those design elements such that
some elements are more or less attention
capturing than others so this is kind of
our first
pass at integrating saliency with an
interactive design tool
um here's another one
where the idea is to retarget or find
alternate layouts for an existing design
now this is a vector design and when you
see the alternate designs they're
designed for a different aspect ratio
and the designs that are generated
actually have saliency operating behind
the scenes
to pick the designs that most closely
match the original design in terms of
its um attention heat maps so just to
kind of show you a side by side
um whoops let me go to the next slide
yeah just to show you a side-by-side and
explain how that works
you see the original design
on the left
sorry i have a bit of a lag
you have the original design on the left
and then
the new design on the right and the idea
of our of our model was to pick this new
design such that the elements that were
most attention capturing in the original
design are still the most attention
capturing elements in the final redesign
um because that's supposed to capture
the intention of the designer and so
here's another application of how
attention can be used in the loop within
a design tool
all right but um as i presented to you
right now both these tools bubble view
and important they work well for data
collection but they depend on um a kind
of artificial image viewing setup
where you're asking participants to
engage with the image or the visual in a
way that they wouldn't naturally so that
this would really be just for data
collection but then we sat and we
thought about whether there might be a
way to capture more natural in the wild
attention patterns from interactions and
what we realized is that while bubble
view is a restricted focus viewer right
so it's a restricted area of focus
around where your mouse cursor is we all
have a restricted
focus viewer in our pockets which is our
cell phone through which we look at this
broader world and so we could use it to
explore images and interpret the zoom
patterns
that's zoom maps interpret the zoom
patterns as
regions of the image
that have the highest importance to that
viewer so
really what we do behind the scenes is
we look at for each pixel the zoom level
that it lies in and for what amount of
time and we interpret that as a value in
our density heat map later
and so this is what it looks like um the
zoom apps for three different viewers of
this large um multiples visualization
you can see where the various uh viewers
zoomed in on and what they found most
interesting
and what's nice is you can relate it to
some tasks you give them so you can ask
them some questions you can have them
explore the visualizations and you can
see you can get them to describe them
afterwards but you can relate what they
choose to explore with what they
describe
and here's an interesting example where
we again take the population view but
now we break up the population in two
and we uh aggregate the zoom patterns of
the population of participants that have
the highest rating from this for this
visualization and on the right hand side
the population of participants that have
the lowest rating for this visualization
and we can see that um on the left are
the participants that um engaged much
more with the visualization they had
similar amounts of time to view it but
the ones on the left explored much more
of it and found it more interesting as a
result
and here's an example of zoom maps
applied to some natural images just to
show you some of that variability now
it's very much the same
story as we saw with importance in that
on an individual by individual basis
we're going to see some differences in
how people view images but once we
aggregate the the data from multiple
participants in this case
after around 20
participants we start to converge
we end up with a average heat map that
looks very much like an eye tracking
heat map
and you can see that average zoom app
with the uh ground truth eye fixations
overlaid on top of it
and of course we can use this as just
another data capture modality for
um figuring out which content to
prioritize um in that image if we have a
thumbnailing application or a
summarization application so while we
could compute individualized summaries
or thumbnails
for each of the observers that viewed
the image we can also aggregate them
together and compute a single
uh population thumbnail a general
thumbnail for that image that represents
the content in that image that's most
interesting to a general population of
observers
and i i mentioned to you earlier that
saliency models have gotten really good
lately um and the data sets have gotten
quite large for capturing attention
patterns and so this is why we're
starting to see them more and more in
industrial application whereas maybe 10
years ago
it would be in every introduction and
motivation what people would find
what what people would find useful for
their saliency model they would describe
these thumbnailing or summarization or
retargeting applications uh now we see
them out in the industry out in the
world and twitter and adobe are two two
of the companies that um use these
models
these same models can be applied to
retargeting and reframing videos to new
aspect ratios
and um in all these cases uh cropping
has been based on the idea of
prioritizing image content where the
saliency models are used to decide
what's important to keep in the crop
but what's important
varies on the context and my claim here
is that depending on how long someone is
looking at something at an image in
particular or even where an image is
viewed or where it's displayed on the
screen is it in the banner is it off to
the side is it the main image on the
screen
that should affect um
uh what the observer takes away from it
they have a different amount of time to
interact with it they'll see a different
portion of that image
and so you might actually want and this
is my claim different crops depending on
how long you think the end consumer will
interact with that image and that was
the premise for uh another piece of work
um done with um in this case the code
charts methodology and this methodology
is uniquely well suited to capture
attention at different viewing durations
as you'll see so the way that this
methodology works and this is going to
loop so hopefully you'll you'll you'll
get a
feel for it you see an image for a fixed
duration of time when the image
disappears you see a grid of three
letter codes the grid of three letter
codes flashes so quickly that then
you're asked to report um what is the
three letter code you were looking at
and because it was so quick that's gonna
be the last point where you looked at on
the image so you're really recording
where your eyes landed last on the image
before that grid of three letter codes
appeared
um and so this is wonderfully fast to
collect attention patterns but one one
thing if you're a keen listener you'll
notice is that we get a single point
where someone's looking for a single
observer at a single duration but
because this is very cheap we can
aggregate this over many observers who
look at the image for different amounts
of time and this is what we do here in
this paper um this is again with um
annelise newman who's
a phd student here
and here what you can see is that the
attention patterns at half a second of
viewing after three seconds of viewing
and after five seconds of viewing are
quite different from each other and we
use that um we can use that for
different applications and so our
proposal in this paper was
this first saliency model that predicted
not a single saliency image but three
saliency images in a single forward pass
through this neural network
and the idea is that
you can pass in an image and and figure
out what the saliency map should look
like for those different durations in
applying them to different applications
like cropping as you see on the left
here uh or prioritizing image content
for and that's what you see a
visualization um for on the right side
of the screen where um we're seeing that
if if people have very little amount of
time to look at something you might only
want to render that portion of the image
and if you're using if you have vrar
applications or you're transmitting that
image across the network
so a lot of the focus um up until this
point in the presentation has been on
using saliency for prioritizing visual
content right for doing image processing
tasks to crop retarget
and otherwise
parse some of these images now i wanna
show you one more application but this
time we're gonna look at saliency as a
way to edit an image so saliency is used
to train a computational model to learn
to edit an image to make certain parts
of that image stand out
and this
model this is gate shift net it takes as
input and image and it takes as input
an object or a region of interest um
that the user supplies um or this could
be replaced by a click that we then
interpret as an object
and what the network does is it predicts
a set of parameters to apply to the
foreground and the background regions of
the image to make
that target object stand out or recede
into the background in the case of
distractor suppression so that's just a
quick diagram of our um of the encoder
part of our network the only key i want
to show you here is that it's a neural
network but that
at the end we're just predicting two
sets of parameters foreground parameters
pf and background parameters and that's
all we're doing and that makes uh our
model able to apply to images of
arbitrary sizes and to videos
because we're not just outputting images
but a set of parameters we can interact
with later as well
so let's take a look at some visual
examples let's look at this archival
photo and this um and our goal here is
to take this bus on the right hand side
and make it pop even more make it more
attention capturing
and you can see um hopefully in this
image
um that our approach successfully
emphasizes the bus while maintaining
fidelity to the input photograph so our
goal is to um
redirect attentions in a subtle way such
that the photo does not look too edited
so there's these complementary
objectives that are working together to
achieve this
um and we can see indeed um if we run a
saliency model over it um that
we succeed in the edited result in
putting more attention on the bus and
now we can use this within graphic
design workflows we want to take this
image and we want to make this about the
bus and we want to make a poster around
it well we can do it using our tool
and the exact same model with uh
somewhat different objective but the
same architecture can be used to
decrease attention to an image region in
this case to say suppress a distractor
um and move attention away from it and
here's a visualization of the attention
um
predicted saliency maps and you can see
that we've indeed succeeded at moving
sailing seat from that back boat to more
towards the front
and here's a stock photo a high-def
photograph
that that we can parse as well and we
might want to emphasize the shoes to
create a product ad and very subtly
manipulate attention towards them and
here's the result of our uh model
um and here is a hiking picture take a
look at the blue backpack on the right
it should pop more now
one last example with the beer glass we
want to make the beer glass on the left
more attention capturing
and
there we go
and we can i mentioned we can apply this
to videos
so
there we go um the video should
ah
sorry my computer is lagging a bit
behind let's try to make this work
okay so
what you should see is two snowboarders
um and what we do is we make the
snowboard stand out
um
that didn't play but you should see now
that the backpack more attention
capturing in this video as well but we
can apply the same methodology frame to
frame
but i mentioned because this is
parametric so we're not predicting a
final image we're predicting a set of
parameters we can hand control back to
the user and allow them to interact with
it and tailor the the image to their
liking so they can dial up or down uh
how salient that that object is intended
to be and that's where they're trading
off realism for attention capture or
they can dig into some of the parameters
that we've predicted
um so sharpness exposure contrast and
adjust them themselves to get the exact
look that they want to go after
okay
and um now i i do have a few final
slides and
i do want to wrap up kind of this uh
big set of projects that i've uh talked
to you about um
in in using attention and what i want
you to notice here is this this common
thread the common thread for all these
projects whether we're parsing images or
graphic designs or visualizations or in
the last case that i just showed you
videos
this was all done in with the use of hci
tools um that um were
measuring and understanding human
perception
that were then used to train machine
learning models
on that collected perceptual data and
then we went full circle and we fed
those models back into interfaces that
would make designer image processing
applications easier or more effective
and this makes um i think this body of
work a very interdisciplinary space and
i'm going to reiterate this again this
is very ripe for continued innovation so
i'd be excited to see more students
in this space merging insights from
human perception with computer vision
computer graphics and machine learning
applications and
that's what drew me to these topics
during my phd and i hope that um i drove
your interest to these topics in this
presentation too
now i want to spend i'm gonna kind of
switch gears a little bit and i'm just
gonna spend five minutes on um a
different area that's been occupying me
um over the last couple of years
at adobe
and this is unreadability
and
it seems like a different topic but
actually much like all the work that
i've presented to you today i'm drawn to
this topic because it's an
interdisciplinary space that leverages
our understanding of human perception
and tools to study human perception into
the design of better tools and in this
case we're focused on reading
and education and literacy
so the premise of this body of work is
that if we tune various typographic
characteristics various features like
the ones i have on the screen here
whether it's font family and font size
and character and line spacing or or we
get um to the full extreme of variable
fonts and we start to tune the
parameters there if you haven't heard of
variable fonts look them up they're
really cool well it turns out if we tune
all these parameters to the individual
reader we can make everyone a better
reader and this holds based on our
research for
young readers for older readers
struggling readers and proficient
readers and what i'm showing you here is
um every line on these visualizations as
an individual so you see some grade
three students on the left here and you
see kind of a sampling of crowdsourced
adults on the right here of varying ages
and
the length of the line is proportional
to their reading gain when a reading
format was tuned to them
so in the in the case of the adults we
just changed what font they read in and
in some cases we saw
uh over 200 words per minute difference
and so
what we're seeing is that
you could translate this to say four or
five extra pages of reading you could do
an hour if you just knew what font was
right for you
and that's what leads us to kind of this
this
really interesting challenge how do we
find the format that works for everyone
because one thing we do see is that it's
so different across individuals there's
no one set or even small set of formats
that work for everyone
everyone could benefit from their unique
personalized font uh format which which
isn't just font it's all these other
characteristics i talked about and we
talk about this as your digital
prescription so what's the equivalent of
the quick optometrist like test um and
we're after this question as well so we
um we have this virtual readability lab
and you can try it out today but we're
continuing to populate it with a set of
uh short tests they're intended to help
an individual narrow in on some features
of their best uh format right now we
just have fonts and spacings but we plan
to expand this and in parallel we're
also looking at um machine learning
models of what personal characteristics
help us figure out
how to tailor a format to that
individual
example test that one would be given
on our vrl and that the kinds of tests
that we give our participants
is we have them read chunks of text in a
particular format we track their reading
speed we ask them comprehension
questions and we repeat this again and
again while varying the format
underneath
uh and we do that in order to be able to
recommend a format to them at the end
based on the reading speeds and
comprehension and as we evolve the suite
of tests we're also looking at
additional metrics of comprehension
comfort fluency um endurance and um and
i promised i'd bring alexandra pakutsuki
back
initially
so she's a collaborator with us looking
at eye tracking um and she was working
on web gazer one of the web uh based eye
tracking methodologies and we're looking
at
what the signatures of the eyes can tell
us about how people read and how that
could lead to a better format for them
so can we use their eyes to figure out
what they're more comfortable reading
and we're doing the same with voice as
well so there's a lot more exciting
directions in which this is going
so
uh as you can see that brings us back
full circle and here um in this
readability project as in the other
projects that i've described to you
today again the focus is leveraging
human perception
for better tool design except that now
the findings can be taken one step
further so rather than just optimizing
the visual
in this case we're optimizing the visual
rendering of the textual
and we're optimizing it to help
individuals ingest information more
easily and i think this is the holy
grail because it's the potential to
contribute to closing the learning gap
and making an impact on education and
literacy and um that makes me very
excited to to work on these topics so
with that i'm gonna close um the main
portion of the talk i'm gonna open up
the zoom floor to questions and i'm
happy to answer them based on any of the
um
topics that i've presented today thank
you very much
i left lots of time for discussion
yes this is great um
and uh i think we already have some
questions so thanks for the talk there
are so many interesting points in this
and i have so many questions but i'll
try and limit myself to one unless maybe
there's some more time at the end but i
can ask another um
one of the questions i had was about the
um salient suit prediction that you were
talking about um
correct me if i'm wrong it seemed like a
lot of the content that was being uh
demonstrated in the talk was more like
one-way
uh content in the center in the sense of
like a producer and they want you to
sort of get to know something like maybe
there's an infographic or just a poster
um i'm wondering if at all the sales
prediction
can act as a proxy for like actual
engagement but when i think of
a lot of advertisement on the internet
there's a talk there's a lot of talk
about like click through and just like
trying to get you to actually engage
um with the content and so i'm wondering
at all if like the failure to prediction
is a proxy um
to that or if there's any sort of like
further to that it definitely yeah it
definitely can be so um in the case of
websites um companies might be
monitoring not just click through rates
but right where the cursor is going in
some cases that's proxy for where your
eyes are moving
um in some cases not because your eyes
can move somewhere while your cursor
isn't but in that case you can take say
beta users or beta testers and have them
look through those websites or user
interfaces and see where their eyes move
and if they even notice your content
right so in what i was showing you was
like let's look at the saliency map of a
particular piece of content but you can
embed that content in other content and
just treat the bigger content as what
you compute the sale and see over what
you measure eye movement so you can see
you can then compare how the attention
um
moves between those various pieces and
do these pieces attract attention more
than those pieces so definitely and
that's done in the industry and
marketers are interested in that too and
i think another example was like the
storefront right because every
individual object has a graphic design
on it that that's optimized to lead your
eyes in a particular way
maybe if it's well designed but then in
in the context of all the other ones all
the other products um
the the research might be like what's
popping out on the shelf when you look
at it all at once right and and then
there's strategic placement where you
might want to place things so that they
stand out from their surroundings so you
can always take the bigger context into
account and compute the sale and see
over that right or run some eye tracking
studies there
right on awesome thank you
yeah
great thank you um
i was wondering uh thank you for this
talk by the way super interesting work
um i was wondering that uh readability
work are you collecting any data on
potential learning differences or um
yeah differences in learning style
definitely so we're not um
um
we're not indexing on the differences in
learning style but we're definitely
capturing different types of say reading
and learning proficiency um and when
when we run this in a crowdsourced way
um we have these very thorough surveys
where we ask every possible question of
um you know
how how
proficient do you self rate yourself to
how proficient do you rate yourself to
be you know whether you've been
diagnosed with reading learning
disabilities whether you read frequently
and how frequently and what kind of
reading do you do do you do reading as
part of your work all of those when
taken together they paint a picture for
how proficient a reader someone is
and
the way that we're talking about this
work is that it's it's not that there's
like a dyslexic population a
non-dyslexic population because that's
the question that comes up right are we
what are
what who are we designing for the
average reader the proficient reader the
dyslexic creator well we're all
somewhere on the spectrum from um not
very proficient to proficient reader and
what our research is showing is that
indeed everyone can can kind of jump up
in that scale and improve their reading
um and and so we we are looking at
different types of reading and in some
targeted ways we're also recruiting
participants with different proficiency
levels in reading so we're looking at
second language learners we're looking
at
adult learners who who are
um struggling to read and and attending
classes in order to do that we're
looking at um children uh in in
classrooms both um
diagnosed dyslexic and cannot but the
the right way to think about this is
that everyone can um
gain some improvements and that we we
have to design for the individual
yeah thank you just a quick follow-up to
that um i was wondering for example as a
starting point um
when you want to customize for for
individuals if you do have some of those
standardized um rating scales that are
used would you be able to make
predictions without having um that like
initial data on each other individuals
well
so we we have some
some data from the different users like
um even their age could put them in a
bucket that would help us recommend
something for them the more we know
about them the more we can recommend to
them so we haven't um used maybe some of
the
standardized learning skills that you're
talking about um but uh we we are trying
to capture as much data as possible in
the studies that we're doing to
understand what uh features of an
individual uh map them to what features
of the reading format uh but in practice
if it deployed depending on where it's
deployed or who it's deployed by and
what tools
you you know you could use whatever data
is available or none at all to try to
offer something so if you know nothing
you you could still offer some formats
that
do generally well but the more and more
you know you can tailor that prediction
better and better and the idea is that
as you tailor it more and more the gains
increase
thank you
thank you so much for the talk uh in the
beginning i think you're
you're saying that you looked at
click-based methods and webcam based
methods because they're more scalable to
collect data
i was i was just wondering like what
about like
ar headsets do you think like as people
wear them or or buy more of them that
would also be like more scalable or like
yeah what are the pros and cons
yeah
definitely um we can see more of that we
i think we haven't seen
the proliferation of ar and vr headsets
in the consumer market as much as maybe
we expected um but maybe that will
change and definitely those those
headsets offer us a way to capture
attention in very natural scenarios
right especially if any of those glasses
um actually take off
then having someone's eye movements as
they uh walk through the world is the
most natural signal we can capture and
we'll answer a whole bunch of different
questions right um because the context
varies so much and and the key is really
to get the data from individuals all
over the world to understand how
attention patterns vary so
another thing to consider is that vr and
ar headsets may end up in some hands and
not others and um we might be pulling
somewhat biased data from that from
those sources as well so there's
any any tool we use to capture attention
can teach us something about how people
look and
in all cases it's a trade-off between
cost
diversity of the population
and accuracy of the signal and we can
make all those trade-offs and like even
with the cell phone cameras today
there's much better tracking available
from the cell phone camera um that then
was available even a few years ago and
cell phones are something that many more
individuals have so i think that um
there's more promise from um cell phone
collection of of eye movement data but
then then it's going to be mostly
limited to the cell phone screen um but
yes
future ar glasses will will give us a
broader view
awesome thank you thank you hi zoya um i
actually have i think a nice follow-up
question which is um
we've been seeing a lot of excitement
around vr and ar and
uh these platforms are really
interesting because they basically let
you create
an entire virtual world or a virtual
overlay for the world
and you've done a bunch of research
looking at
how
human perception works and how we can
manipulate visual content to change how
people perceive it and i'm i'm wondering
what you think the interesting research
directions are in this space when we are
able to control not just like a single
image that somebody is looking at but
they're basically entire surroundings
that they perceive yeah and and it's
kind of scary right that kind of a
feature it has a black mirror like
flavor to it of uh what do you block out
from your visual field of view and um i
i think that
uh it's
it would be easier if it's controlled by
the individual user right rather than
it's controlled by some third party um
where you might have preferences for
what you want to look at or what you
don't and and you why very much those
same preferences when um you know you
use your computer and your browser and
there's certain things you block and and
certain things you ignore um so
if you could apply those same filters to
the real world i mean in some cases
people talked about some of these
applications of blocking out
advertisements right like
um like the blocker you have in chrome
just apply to the real world because i
don't want to see that stuff so um i
could imagine those kinds of
applications i mean another like our
video screens and zoom is is a kind of
you know first stage proxy of what ar
looks like and and we have
these um virtual backgrounds we have
people we can change how they um look to
us and they could change how they look
to us so we're already doing that um and
actually there's a very relevant paper
that that google um just put on archive
i think this this past year um showing
that they could do distractor removal
and zoom so this is very similar to the
work that i showed you where um
they they can take a real background and
then just suppress right change like
like make this green tree blend into the
background so it's less distracting
right and um really manipulate um so it
then it's a transition between a
completely virtual background in the
real world but we're kind of already
living it um so we'll see we'll see um
as it expands to beyond the computer
screen that we can walk away from and
see everything unfiltered what happens
when you start to filter content
advertisers will obviously use it too so
if the individuals have some control
uh left right to to turn some of those
things on or off that'll be important
yeah thank you i think it's really
interesting to think about how you would
give people ability to
gain back more control over what they're
what they're perceiving
and you might have thoughts too annalise
because you were featured on a lot of
these slides and
yeah um
yeah no i mean i think
i i think i sort of share your intuition
that
applying human perception sort of too
aggressively to fully virtual spaces
could like there are a lot of people who
have who are really motivated to try to
capture people's attention um and
putting sort of
tools out in the world that allow
like advertisers or social media
companies for example to have even more
control over people's visual perception
um is a little bit alarming to me so i i
think there is um
sort of a an onus on researchers to try
to figure out like how do we how do we
give more control back to the perceiver
and also how can we use these tools for
um for more beneficial purposes so
you know when we were doing some of our
memorability work we were thinking about
um
you know applications potentially in
education for how to highlight content
that people would be more likely to
retain
your readability work has a lot of
connections to education as well um
but yeah
i think those are important points too
is that one right is releasing the tools
back to the community to the research
community to the education community to
leverage their needs right as as opposed
to just close it leaving it behind
closed doors right and the second is
giving that to the individuals giving
some of the designing tools are with the
individual and mind around the
individual right so that they can
personalize
what they see
yeah
great um
we have uh maybe one last question i
sort of want to follow up on that um
when henry was just saying
uh how do you weigh
uh
releasing uh a tool like the one that
your your team did an open source tool
when like it has the potential to just
you know sort of be exploited by
advertisers and whatever to
um you know to control a little bit more
perception right like like what is that
what is the like
the judgement call there
for which for any of these tools for the
laughter
yeah yeah yeah like how do you weigh
like uh benefiting the research
community versus um like potential
misuse by members of industry well i
mean that's a tough question for anyone
in computer science and artificial
intelligence because pretty much any
technology you put out can be misused
and i i the approach that that i take is
to
try to release it openly as much as
possible because that way it doesn't
it it can end up in all hands kind of
equally right and
um by by talking to the right
individuals or or to get it in front of
the right individuals you can make sure
that it um there's good use cases for it
in education right um and in you know we
were talking about social media but
how we can also
uh educate people better about the
social media so we can take their
attention and put it on the visuals not
just on the text and make sure that they
engage more with the um infographic or
the visualizations that they they're
more motivated to explore the data
themselves um there's
even with the same kind of agencies
there's ways to use that content
um in all sorts of ways right you can
also um use it to bring people's
attention to the warning on labels on on
product boxes right just as much as you
can on them buying that box in the first
place
um i you know as researchers like i
chase interesting questions that tell me
something about human perception the
more you know the more can hurt
but
um but also the more you know the more
you can find um ways of of kind of
hacking um tools to to improve
perception right and to bridge some gaps
right in the case of readability as well
we're trying to close some of the
education gaps and if you make something
more visible more salient for people who
might have missed that you're bridging
those gaps as well um and while creating
others so
yeah this it's not an answer it's a it's
an ongoing philosophical discussion with
with all of us in computer science and
ai and that's our role to also figure
that out especially as as beyond the phd
and we go out into the real world we can
have real impact so um i think that's
important to think about
appreciate it thank you thank you
great
well thank you so much zoya this was a
fantastic talk and it's great to see
uh really the interdisciplinary core of
the work that you're doing
you